the reason why I like I just realized
now is because I honestly believe that
if I walked up to Dahlia and go hey how
do you think my career is going
daliyah was going yeah you don't lie in
your career you know and there's gonna
be more that's gonna happen yeah if I
said to Eric I think Eric Griffin he
would do something positive as well I
feel like you would warn me I would give
you some heads up yeah like dude if you
keep doing those kind of movies or if
you you know I would tell you the truth
you would absolutely that's what I feel
that's why I like you so much I would
tell anyone any of my friends so how was
I go yeah really not good if it wasn't
good
I know but let's say I was sensitive
like super sensitive guy that's this
sort of role that I take in his life
because I've had to be the bearer of bad
news your reality and he it is hard to
tell someone that thing you were in so
it wasn't good it wasn't good some
things you have to say you have to but
it but but they say it out of love
okay I want to have a question for you
yeah you know you know splitting up
together though and the Valentine's
episode you saw it yes I watched it how
was I in it I thought that the overall
episode was not very strong I thought
you were the strongest part about it you
were very cute I know you didn't like
yourself in it no but in front because
you're just gonna be overly critical no
that's not what it is is right because
by you saying that that overall because
the whole thing was my story no how the
[ __ ] is it I just it's a storyline thing
you can't control Bobby but did did it
garner like did it make me laugh it did
you made me laugh in all of your parts
you always make me laugh okay but other
things that you've done and we've fought
about this where you're like how is that
scene and I was like not good and you
say no I thought I was pretty good and I
and I tell you know that wasn't good one
time dude
one time I was on the run and we just
box it out when the first episode of
love Erin yeah she said to me cuz cuz I
hadn't been in anything for a while she
saw and she goes you asked you asked I
know I go what do you think shake maybe
you should take an acting class first
that you said hey that's not the first
thing I said I said you know no no [ __ ]
no I didn't see
I did see it also can I say this did you
take it
can I say this did you heat hurt at the
end of the year Paul rust right that
star of the show I saw the show
said to me write that scene with Gillian
Gillian Gillian that's what I said
yeah Gillian was so real and it's at the
time I don't know he said some positive
things about it
look I'm also not the gatekeeper he
obviously is it's just my opinion
hmm ask me about splitting up together
Oh splitting up together I don't care
what you say because I know what it is
what am I gonna say something [ __ ]
and negative like you guys did back when
we were building railroads back in the
day that's not true at all ask me about
splitting up together go ahead what do
you think of spirits pulling up together
honestly yeah it was really good I'm
serious how do you read that Bobby it
was really good you know I believe him
really good yeah well it was fun and
cute it was fun and cute there was
something else you've done what have you
see me in remember give me a resume all
right we just think of me and uh the
keeping up with the Joneses sad dictator
good good very good very good
the first Harold and Kumar good very
good I crushed it you crushed you did
very well fellas good I know I crossed
it okay go on
okay what'd you think of about me and um
MADtv
what is what's MADtv what what is it you
owe the sketch show yeah oh boy yeah you
were great fine
all right you know what you were you
were you were fine can I ask unless to
talk about you then I'm kidding it was
ask me about you you know that movie you
did very late without nobody did the
remake of the room what they did with
earth is amazing I do we just talked
about this at lunch I know you know you
were the best part
man thanks really good acting no why why
I was so good they couldn't even use my
words right they go you're so [ __ ]
good we can't even have you talk in this
[ __ ] riot did he warn you No well you
just find out hurt your family didn't
hurt and I'm gonna take that I saw the
movie once and I saw there was one scene
in the very back I just see this
sticking out of a hedge very good stop
I'm a pretty good actress
you beat me out of mixology I did are
you going for the same part I did refer
his part and I was terrible so it
doesn't even matter I was happy for you
actually you know so funny know what
they said verbatim they said you you got
the part after I read they go do you got
the part and I go was there anybody in
contention they go yes I'm ching chong
guy but we didn't want him at all okay
and I said resi you're saying they say
yeah some I was about to give you a
compliment okay go go go go go and you
go into that I don't want and we talked
about this at lunch I don't want to talk
about anything I'm not gonna no we're
not gonna talk about that let me see I
want to give you a compliment [ __ ]
okay when D'Elia and I we have talked
about this already we have on this yeah
we have okay that's it but I appreciate
it okay
[Music]